was your name Jennifer no it's Jennifer
with two y's I used to be Jennifer but
then I decided to Rebrand myself
oh wait hang on it's on X o'clock
um
well nice to meet you my name's April
and I just wanted to say that your dress
is so cute it's Bonks I saw my spinning
instructor wearing it and I was like
shut up where do I get that oh my God
who's your spinning instructor Gregory
or Winona I go to Giannis who are
Gregory and Winona I've never heard of
them before are they better Winona rocks
my world seriously you need to get me in
there like that's a must must must she's
the worst person I've ever met
I want to travel the world with her this
is awesomely perfect Burley just moved
in with his rich girlfriend and we need
help with the rent we have a couple
House rolls though yeah sure of course
you can't use the front door you have to
climb in through the back window no
personal phone conversations if you ever
speak to me in Spanish please use the
formal usted and no electricity after 6
pm
okay you can use as much free
electricity as you want it's free a
couple more rules if you ever watch a
sad movie you have to wear mascara so we
can see whether or not you've been
crying there's no noise a lot of Mondays
and no TV after breakfast
because it's hard to tell no we leave
the TV on all day long so burglars think
that we're home and we're not which is
my idea uh that I'm trying to patent so
you want to move in tonight
we're getting close
babe you look more beautiful right now
than I have ever seen you
wow just your luck that you're going
into labor on Halloween can I get a warm
towel to get that makeup off no I want
it on that's the whole point I put the
makeup on after I went into labor
whatever blows your skirt up okay you
ready to push
wait no babe my birth Max
here comes a contraction are you ready
okay I'm ready
it caught on in a Flash Jeremy Jam is
not pleased that I punched him in the
face on the night of Leslie's wedding he
is suing me thirteen thousand dollars
for orthodontic surgery six thousand for
enamel repair and 46 million for
psychological damages yeah that seems
about accurate that guy is the worst we
should sue Jam's parents for spawning a
human turd burger
ladies and gentlemen for the first time
ever in her new part-time job in the
public health department at City Hall
Meredith Brookins yay oh Leslie this is
so nice I put poisonous gas in one of
these balloons so if any of them pops
you may die oh April we would all die
gases fill the volume of whatever
container they're in
School
secrets
stolen
from deep inside you know this song
already of course I do everyone knows a
song that's amazing the drum beats out
of time if you're lost you can look and
you will find me Time After Time if you
fall I will catch you I will be waiting
Time After Time Time After Time Time
After Time
it's never happened
you think I have been around the world
I've Been Everywhere darling I'm a very
wealthy woman my husband's kept me in
the finest clothes from Bergdorf Goodman
you see freeze FBI no leave me alone I
didn't kill anybody and I didn't burn
down the middle either my sister did but
now she's been eating my walls
nothing to see here first up please
welcome April Ludgate
hello
April Ludgate
[Music]
I'm 20 years old
I like
people
places
and things and Pawnee is my favorite
place in the world
[Applause]
I'm going to do Impressions oh celebrity
Impressions that's that's wild yep
um this is an impression of my sister
hi I'm Natalie I love Ritalin and have
low self-esteem
thank you
this is an impression of my boss Leslie
Knope
women should do everything check out my
four color pen hey everybody listen up
while I talk about some really really
important stuff practice
get Penguins Park sugar packs we heard
100 pitches and they're all terrible
change of plans you guys are my idea
Factory April go okay I got one macaroni
and poison it's like mac and cheese but
with a special ingredient
hey Ann Ann called she wants her ugly
outfit back
why are you dressed as a pilgrim Leslie
said it was to come as you were in the
90s party I assumed it was the 1690s
babe if it was the 1690s we'd all be
mummies what do you think mummies are
skeletons oh boy is this going to be one
of those cool bachelorette parties where
things get out of control and we murder
someone and then we all have to take a
blood Oak to never reveal our secret no
but I might have to leave early having
fun well four years of work down the
drain and I have a penis on my head Jam
is stealing this lot right out from
under us my dream is dead Anne mine too
this is why I prefer a nightmare so what
do we got so far we need big ticket
items I got the Red Hot Chili Peppers to
send us a signed guitar that's great
April how'd you do that it's a long
story but the short version is I'm
currently catfishing Anthony Kiedis so I
propose that we change our name from the
subcommittee for pitification to the
subcommittee for Lodge beautification
April stop that who are you texting you
oh
she's texting me
I'm sorry you're bored
of the 25 entrance today only one has
deemed himself worthy of a sommelier
certificate oh my God are you sure no
way oh my God thank you thank you thank
you so much everyone I think we can
agree that all wine tastes the same and
if you spend more than five dollars on
wine you are very stupid security I just
want to thank all the people that got me
here Norbit uh Pluto Nash all the clumps
it takes like eight hours to cook
something in this thing I guess I could
pick up a brisket tomorrow and start it
for dinner Thursday well Thursday's no
good I have production meetings all day
and we've got dinner with Joe and Don on
Friday hey you know Sunday we go to the
farmer's market put the brisket in the
slow cooker get a movie on paper review
the new Jason Bourne movie's supposed to
be pretty funny
yep follow it to me guys just go into
the parking lot for normal government
reasons
sorry I can't go through with this I was
gonna pull a prank
I hear these guys in ski masks to kidnap
us and I was gonna pretend to be a hero
they were going to shoot me and drive
the van into the river and that's when
the divers would go in pull you guys out
of the water and I would be standing on
the shore like hey get pranked much what
the I even got these squibs from a
special effects guy and I was gonna say
this code word and that's when I would
push this button no
[Applause]
no all over me
thank you
I mean it
Ben that was amazing really best prank
ever
all right